and Jason from Texas writes since you've
been getting all kinds of requests for a
new version of the creepy clown I think
it's time to turn into its own new
segment it doesn't have a jingle so I
put one together for you I hope you like
it writes Jason from Texas so he put
together a jingle for the segment where
we do the creepy clown voice here's the
jingle jingle right that's right yeah
some people write us by the way and say
you guys hit you explain that too often
it's like look sometimes it's the first
show some people are gonna listen to us
we always used to say about comics just
every comic book is some kids first
comic book so you always have to write
with that in mind you can't just always
be like I assume everyone's up up to up
to speed with what we're doing and so I
always like to do the kind of this is
the history a reason of the creepy clown
but now that [ __ ] theme song ruins
speaking of which Tony and Phoenix
Wright's been listening since episode 1
and I've heard all the great creepy
clown goodness for the entire run of the
show and the last impressions of do I've
heard you only once briefly do Bobcat
Goldthwait could you do Bob head as the
creepy clown you would be my hero baby
he writes I don't know what that means
you know I'm gonna be like a hero baby
like a very heroic baby you mean a baby
in a diaper in a cape maybe forgot the
comma yeah so he wants to hear Bobcat
Goldthwait doing the creepy clown to you
I wanna hear those well okay this could
trash my voice for the rest of the night
so I hope you enjoyed me so far
because I won't sound the same after
this so dramatically a half second
before is about to begin again
we took a big like [ __ ] lung full of
air man you like I'm getting ready to
scream and I know it's gonna be loud and
so I just got happy requiem for a dream
movie man there you go there's your
Bobcat Goldthwait and your Bobcat goofy
I was looking at your vein it looked
like it was about to go yeah one of
those Julia Roberts moments where I just
gonna
[Music]
you
[Music]